you got to have a purpose have a vision
I was very
fortunate that I stumped on my
vision I mean as you know I was born in
1947 in Austria after the second world
war and I didn't really like Austria
when I grew up I couldn't wait to get
out of there I couldn't see myself
becoming a
farmer or a worker in a factory or
anything like that even though my
parents wanted me to stay there and have
a normal
life my father wanted me to become a
police officer like he was my mother
wanted me just to stay there and marry a
girl with the name of Heidi hopefully
and have a bunch of kids and run around
like the fap family in a sound of music
but that was their Vision not mine my
vision was totally different I felt that
I was born for something special for
something unique for something big